hi guys and welcome to my course on
introduction to asp.net core
mvc and we'll be using dotnet 5.
i have seen many people struggle with
the concept of
mvc or getting to know how dot net core
is different as compared to classic.net
do not worry i have you covered if you
need an introduction
on what are the basic files and folders
in a.net core project
or how do you add database to the
project how do you connect with entity
framework core
and much more before you take this free
course
i want you to be familiar with basics of
c sharp
and have a basic understanding of how
sql queries work
and sql server if you have that
then this course will be easy to follow
along
before i walk you through what will be
covered in this free course
i would appreciate if you would like and
subscribe to the channel
so that you will be notified for all of
the new free content
that i will be posting that being said
let's take a look at what we'll be
covering in this free course
we will first start with the
fundamentals of asp.net core
and the reason behind its evolution
after that we will see what are the
files and folder structures
and we will understand what are basic
terminologies
like pipeline middlewares routing
etc in a.net core mvc application
once we get our solid foundation then we
will add database to our project
using entity framework core with that
will be able to perform crud operations
which stands for create read update and
delete
those are the basic topics that we'll be
covering in this free course but
that's not it once we have a functional
crud operation website
we will be deploying that to azure to
see everything
coming live with our database
so we'll be building a website and will
be deploying it to
azure but along with that the most
important thing is assignments
and error solving i will be giving you
assignments to practice the basic grad
operations
and you'll see common errors that we see
and how to resolve
those so join me in this exciting
journey
of learning asp.net core mvc
with net core 5. before we get started
i want to show you where you can get all
the project resources
if you go on.netmastery.com and courses
i will have all of the courses listed
right here
now the free version that you'll see is
a free version of the complete course
asp.net core
mvc up and running part 1. if you click
on the details here
and if you click on github code you will
have the complete code
we won't be building everything in this
free course
but if you go on the comments here and
if you scroll down
you go to the older comments you will
see exactly on what was being changed
like this section is included and if you
click on here
you will see what was changed in that
git comment
so if you face any issues you can come
on github
and you can check everything there one
place for all the resources
will be dotnet mastery if you click on
details
you will be able to get all the course
content
and the github code along with live
preview
of the course so that being said now you
know how to get
all of the project resources it is
through dotnetmastery.com
before we get started let's understand
on what are
all the softwares that we will need for
this course
the first software will be sql server
2019
you can also use any older version of
sql server
that's fine with me but if you want you
can download the latest
version scroll down here and you can
install the developer version
since it is the free edition once you
have sql server
then we need visual studio 2019
now the net core version that we are
using is dotnet 5
and that is available in preview right
now since
it has not been released yet so for that
you will need
visual studio 2019 preview
you can come here and download the
community version
and install it along with that you will
also have to install.net core5
so you can install this and right now
the preview version
is preview 5. but the course that we
will be building
was built using preview 4. because of
which in the course you will see i
installed packages and everything for
preview 4.
but what you need to do is when you
create the project
whatever preview version you use make
sure to use that same preview version
throughout the course
in all the packages or the installation
that we do
once the dotnet core 5 is released i
will update this
and let you know to install.net core 5
and not to work with the preview version
that being said if you do not want to
work on the preview versions
and you would rather work on visual
studio 2019
you can follow along with the course as
well
for that you'll install visual studio
2019
and net core 3.1 the course will be
compatible
with that as well so that's all the
tools and technology that you will need
install them if you do not have them and
join me
from the next video in this video i want
you to walk you through the journey of
dot net core
dot net core is probably the biggest
change that dart net language
has encountered in 2002
microsoft introduced web forms which was
a revolution
at that time but as the time progressed
there was need to organize things and
with other drawbacks in picture
came a new architecture which was
asp.net
mvc now even though i love
mvc it had its flaws like
it was created on top of the components
for web forms because of that it was
tied to iis
and windows but as the web evolved
microsoft had to keep up with the change
with that finally in june of 2016
microsoft released asp.net core and
it was the first version now asp.net
core is built on top of the new dotnet
core framework
it is cross-platform version and hence
it is not tied with windows
also net core was built with cloud in
mind
so it is extremely ravished with that
then in august of 2018 microsoft
released.net code 2.0
and microsoft team has been very active
with releasing the new version
as you can see in september of 2019
dotnet code 3
was released in the intermediate
versions there was darknet code 2.1
and 2.2 there was quite a big change
coming from 2.1 to 2.2
with respects to identity but with all
the versions
upgrading to the new version has not
been that difficult
then in december of 2019 dotnet code
was released which had a long-term
support
finally in november of 2020 dotnet 5
will be released
this.net core 5 is right now in the
preview version
and will be using that to create our
project
so that is just a small journey for the
dotnet core frameworks that have been
encountered that being said why one
should use dotnet core
as compared to the classic.net there are
quite a few advantages
first is the asp.net core is fast and
open source
next benefit is it is cross-platform
the classic.net was tied to windows and
iis
but when asp.net code was rewritten
it removed that dependency with asp.net
core
we get the built-in support for
dependency injection
dependency injection saves a lot of time
and it is extremely helpful
as we proceed with the course you will
see the benefits that dependence
injection
brings to the picture then the updates
to new versions for dotnet code are easy
because of that you can always keep up
with the new versions
dotnet core is also cloud friendly
when asp.net code was rewritten it was
written in a way to make sure that they
had the cloud architecture in mind
another benefit and one of the most
important one of asp.net core framework
is its higher performance with the new
enhancements as well as upgrades the
code
actually gets much more optimized that
results
into improved performance the asp.net
core compiler will
eventually optimize the entire code
whenever
the code is recompiled using asp.net
core
framework asp.net core's actual
performance is multiple
times more than any of the famous
framework implementations because of
that it is clear
that microsoft has quite a long term
plan
with this asp.net code technology
so with that let's continue learning in
the next video
what we want to do first is we want to
create our project
so for that we will open up visual
studio 2019
right now i am on the preview version
because we do not have the dotnet 5
released
so we'll be using the preview version
with the.net 5
of preview as well so in here
we will create a new project
then we have a list of all of the
templates that are available
what we want is asp.net core web
application
you can also search for that if you
cannot find it
once we select that we will hit the next
button
and then we need to give project name
location
and a solution name i will call this as
rocky and i'll change the location to
where i want to save it
so i'll select the location and we will
hit the create button
once you hit the create button it will
give you more
options that you can configure for
asp.net code
web application right here you can see
the version
which is asp.net core 5.
along with that you can see right here
we are on the preview version right now
now if you'll be taking this course in
the future preview versions might be
different
so make sure that you select the most
latest preview version
and then in all the other places make
sure you use that exact preview version
that being said once you have the dotnet
core and asp.net core 5 here
on the right hand side you can select
authentication
if you hit change here you have no
authentication
individual users account worker school
or windows authentication
now i could go with individual users
account and get a built-in
authentication but i want to set
everything up from the scratch so we'll
go with no authentication
and then later in the course we will add
authentication
that being said in the advanced we have
the configure for
https we will select this we do not want
to go into docker details right now
so i will skip this next i will enable
the razer runtime compilation now
previously enable razer runtime
compilation
was not available here and you had to
add a new git package for that
but now they have added this in the
options
and i think this was a much needed move
because razer runtime compilation
is one of the core features that you
need when developing application
this enables that if you make some
changes to javascript file and
if you save the application go back and
refresh
it automatically populates the changes
rather than restarting the application
so that's enough details about that we
will make sure that this box is checked
and then the main thing here is what
template that we want
now here there are quite a few template
we can start with an
empty project api project web
application
which is razer pages or mvc
application i will go with the mvc
application
and this will give us a basic setup for
an mvc application
we don't have the authentication and
once everything
looks exactly like i have let's hit the
create button
this will create our project and it will
add few files and templates to our
project
great so our project has been added and
right here we see quite a few files
let's continue working on this in the
next video
our project has been created and it's
time to take a look at the files and
folders that we have inside our project
the first file will be the project file
that we will be taking a look at
for that if you right click on the
project you will see the option
of edit project file other way of
accessing that file
is just double click on rocky that will
load the project file by default
now here in the project file you should
notice the target framework
that we are using is dotnet core f5
so this will be the dotnet framework
that we will be using
for our solution if you are using
3.1 or 3.0 that is the version you will
see
right here then we have few more
elements
and the other important entity will be
the item group
item group will have all of the third
party packages that we will be
installing
in our project right now when we created
the project
we selected the runtime compilation on
the project options
because of which it has added that nuget
package
right here when we will be adding more
packages
like we'll be adding database packages
email packages
all of those will be added in the item
group
and we'll be watching them once we add
new packages
in the upcoming videos when you have to
add the package you do not have to come
here and manually add the line
we will be doing that using new kit
packages
that being said this looks good for our
project file
let's continue with the other files in
the next video
next important file that i want to show
you is the program.cs
now we won't be going through all the
files in the same order
but i will be going through them in an
order that will be easier for you to
understand the next file we'll be taking
a look
is the program.cs if we scroll down here
you will see that there is a main method
main method
is more common in console application
and the reason you see that here is
initially.net core application
starts as a console application
the main method configures asp.net core
and starts it the configuration is done
by calling the create host
builder and as you can see this is a
method
in the program class which returns an
object of ihost builder
on this object build and run are called
and then onwards the application will
become
an asp.net core application
the create host builder calls default
builder
which configures the web host using
defaults
also you can see the web builder is
configured
using the startup file before we take a
look at the startup file in detail
let's understand a core concept of
asp.net
core which is dependency injection
in this video before we take a look at
the other files i will introduce you to
a new concept
which is dependency injection asp.net
core implements a simple built-in
dependency injection container
dependency injection is an integral part
of asp.net core architecture
dotnet core injects objects of
dependency classes
through constructor by using the
built-in ioc container
that being said let me try to explain in
simple words
what dependency injection is and what
benefit
it brings let's consider a scenario
without dependency injection
so in any application let's say we have
three pages right now
and we have some common functionality
that we want to use
across all the three pages like email
and database access now let's imagine
that on all of these pages we need
access to database first
so what we will do is we will create the
database object
on all the three pages and in our case
we'll call the class name
sdb then we'll have to do the same then
create
object of the email implementation that
we have in
all the three pages for the email class
now consider a scenario what happens if
in future
you change the implementation of how you
access the database or
email based on the current configuration
you might have to make changes in all
the three pages
which is a big mess another issue here
is on each page you have to deal with
creating the object managing them as
well as disposing them
and that would consume time in each and
every page
which is a bad approach so that being
said
what is a solution to avoid all of this
the answer is dependency injection with
dependency injection
let's first see how the scenario would
look like
we will again have all the three pages
and the email and database functionality
here along with all the things that we
had before we will have something new
which is a dependency injection
container
then we will have the email and database
functionality
but rather than having them in just
classes
we will also have an interface for email
and database
then our classes will be implementing
those interface
and we will register the interfaces in
our dependency injection container as
you can
see so we will tell dependency injection
container
that i email is an interface and email
is implementation of that interface
when any page will need to access these
functionalities
it will just ask the dependency
injection container
to create object of this functionality
and directly give us the object to use
so inside the page we will actually be
using
interfaces and then dependency injection
does all its magic of passing the object
when the website needs it
that way we do not have to deal with
creating the object disposing or
managing that object
inside our pages our pages will look
very clean with just the interface and
all the instance and implementation
will be done by the dependency injection
container
now in future if you want to change or
replace the email class
you do not have to make any change in
the pages
all you have to do is you just need to
change the implementation that you do
in the dependency injection container in
one location
also as i have said before creating and
disposing object
is now the responsibility of the
built-in dependency injection container
and we do not have to worry about it
anymore
which is a great relief so you can see
that there are lots of advantages
that dependency injection brings to the
architecture
that being said with net core we have
the built-in dependency injection
container
now how do we register these
dependencies or where do we register
these dependencies
let's understand a part of that in the
next video
we had to take a detour to understand
dependency injection
before we understand the next file which
is startup right here
you can right click here and go to the
definition
or you can open up the startup file from
here itself
now startup class as you can see is a
basic class
with no extensions or implementations of
interface
but the first thing that you notice if
you scroll down is that there are two
methods
the first one is the configure services
and the next one
is the configure method both of these
methods are invoked automatically
by asp.net core configure services
gets called first we will be registering
all the dependencies with dependency
injection container
that is built in in asp.net core
within the configure services so that is
why i wanted to introduce you to
dependency injection
in the previous video because configure
services
is the place where you do the
registration of your service
if we switch back to the powerpoint the
step that we do when we register our
email and database with
interface as well as the implementation
that is the step that we will do
inside configure services method so
inside the configure services method we
can add services to the collection
of services services are basically
any functionality that you want to
register so
other parts of application can use it
as we saw it could be email database and
much more
we will be registering the services
provided by the dotnet code framework
as well as custom services that we will
create
as of now you can see right here we just
have one services
which is add controllers with views and
with this we register mvc service to
our application we will be adding more
services here
but before we dive into mvc in the next
video
let's understand the configure method
but remember that configure services
method gets called by the runtime
and we use this method to add services
to our container
that being said let's continue in the
next video
in the last video we took a look at
configure services
next method that we have here is the
configure method
here we see the i application builder as
well as the iweb host environment
environment we are using only to check
if it's development
or if it's something else based on that
we are configuring the pipeline
but the i application builder configures
the http request pipeline
of asp.net core the pipeline specifies
how the application should respond to
http request
let's take a look at this with an
example so
in order to understand what the pipeline
is let me switch to the presentation
here
we have different browsers here and then
we have a pipeline
the pipeline specifies how the
application
should respond to http request
when your application receives a request
from the browser
the request goes back and forth through
the pipeline
in the pipeline you can add items that
you want
pipeline is made up of middlewares and
mvc is a middleware itself
so if we want an application to be built
using mvc
we need to add that middleware other
examples could be authentication
middleware authorization middleware
session middleware static files
middleware and much more
so what exactly happens is when your
request will go through
each middleware it can get modified by
them
and eventually it is either passed to
the next middleware
and if that is the last middleware in
the pipeline the response is returned
back to the server
let's take a look at the few middlewares
that are already added in our
application
so if we switch back to the code inside
the configure method
first we are checking if the environment
is development
then we are adding a middleware for
developer exception page
else we have the exception handler which
displays a custom error message
because we do not want to show them the
developer or the coding error
then the next middleware is use https
redirection
this forces the user to use a secure
line
and then we are adding static files what
i mean by static files is that
any web project needs styling javascript
images and much more so all of the
static content will be served by our
application
only because we added the middleware to
use the static files
then we are adding the routing
middleware followed by authorization
middleware
you can see authorization is added
before the end points
right here and that is because order
matters when it comes to the middleware
when a request comes in it is passed
from the first middleware to the second
to the third
and so on in endpoint we configure the
default route for our application
that being said before we understand the
endpoints in more detail
let me explain you routing in the next
video
inside the configure method we have seen
the use routing
as well as use endpoints that being said
we haven't seen the actual mvc routing
and how that works endpoint routing has
been
introduced in asp.net core 3.
in the initial version of asp.net core
routing was a part of mvc but it has
been separated out
to make routing available to all the
middlewares
and not just mvc whenever a request
comes in
it hits an endpoint and that endpoint is
processed by the middleware before we
get into those details
let me switch to presentation and i can
give you example
of routing the url pattern for routing
is considered after the domain name
so in this case it will be after
localhost and the port number
which is five five five then
in the example url that we have we see
category forward slash index forward
slash three
in an mvc application the first thing
that you will see
will be the name of the controller after
that we will have the name of the action
followed by the id also keep in mind
that id
is an optional field some of these
fields can be
optional and if they are not present it
will take the default value
like if an action name is missing it
will default the action name to be
index you can change the defaults if you
want
but if we switch back to our application
and if we see the end point that we are
using
we have a default pattern in which we
have the controller name
defaulted to home action name defaulted
to
index and we have an id property which
is
optional so with that in place let's try
to see some more examples here
in the first example we have forward
slash category
forward slash index so in that case
category will be the controller
index will be the action we do not have
anything for the id
so id will be null
next what we have is only category
in that case the controller will be
category controller
and action will be defaulted to index
action
and if no id is present it will be null
then we have category forward slash edit
forward slash three we have all the
fields here
controller will be category edit
will be the action and id will be three
in the last example we have product
forward slash
details forward slash three again we
have all the three entities
controller will be the product action
will be details
and id will be three now
in mvc there is a route table which
tries to match
endpoints to find out where to pass the
request
to be on track here if we have a url
like this
in mvc home would point to a controller
an index would point to an action method
as we saw in the last slide
now if you are not aware about what is a
controller
what is an action method do not worry
right now
just understand that this is one way of
routing
we will be getting into mvc details very
shortly
but asp.net core is now more than just
an mvc application
it can also have razer pages and signalr
that being said it is possible to have
all three
in a single application all of these
technologies have middlewares
that register endpoints so if we switch
back to our application
right here we see a middleware of use
routing
in startup.cs so let's imagine at some
point we hit this middleware
at this point the request will inspect
all of the registered endpoints
they can be endpoints registered by mvc
or
any other technology it determines
whether it should send the request to
mvc
or any other technology then
for all the middlewares that will be
executed after this
we'll know that endpoint has been
selected like
mvc or razer pages
and then later on when it hits the end
point
in the use endpoints we will register
the endpoint
and then when the request arrives at
this point
it will be processed by the end point
that was selected
in use routing so in expression
we have the end points and we have an
object for the options on this object
there are several
extension methods that are available to
register
different end points like right here we
are registering the mvc
then we have other end points for razor
and signalr as well
we will be adding razer endpoint later
in the course
and within the controller which is the
mvc we have added a default pattern
so by default it will load the home
controller and index
action if nothing has been loaded so
here we also have registered a default
route for mvc application
which has a controller name home and an
action method called as
index this map controller route uses
routing table to match against the
request
this is the basic overview of routing
middleware that we have
that being said before i actually run
the application and walk you through
routing in demo
let me finish the overview of the other
files and then we'll get back to routing
and view it live in action
in this video i want to introduce you to
appsettings.json
this is the file in which we'll be
adding all of the connection strings
and static files like secrets that we
want
in a production application you can move
this to words or secrets
but we'll be using app settings for this
course
here right now we see the logging and in
that we have some things that have been
configured
we will be adding connection strings
along with other things in this course
inside the app settings
whenever there are any keys or anything
that we want to use throughout the
course
it is a great place to store them right
here
that being said we'll come back to this
file and we'll be adding new things in
the upcoming videos
next what we want to see here is we have
a folder
called www root
this folder has been created since we
selected the mvc
application in here if you expand this
there are more folders
that has static files for our
application
static files could be css javascript
or any of the third-party libraries
you can also have images here or html
templates
if you remember in startup.cs if we go
there
we added a middleware use static files
and that was added
so that the application can use the
static files that we add
inside www root
this www root folder will be the root
folder in application
for all static files none of the c
sharp files will be placed in this
folder
this folder is only meant to serve all
the static files for our application
so we'll be using the static files
folder extensively throughout the course
when we have to add images or we want to
add any class libraries
or we want to modify external css
once we have that the last thing that we
have is launch settings.json
launch settings.json is inside the
properties folder
and if we double click it displays
different profile
in which we can run the application like
here if the profile is iis express
it sets the environment variable for
that profile to be development
this way you can configure more profiles
that you want
with the url as a support and other
functionalities
also when we will run the application
right here
we will be seeing all the profiles that
we have set up
inside the launch settings so right here
you can see iis express
and we have the rocky profile if you
want to modify them
you can modify here directly or you can
also do the same if you right click here
and here if you go to the properties we
will be having
those profiles in the debug tab so right
here
you see iis express as well as rocky
we can set the browser url and we can
set the environment variables that we
want
here we have the other settings which
you can set from that page
or we can do in the launch settings.json
now we won't be tweaking this much
because this is more related to
deployment and if you want to add more
environment variable
for like staging another environment but
we'll just keep it with the basic
for this course so with that we have
covered
all of the files that we see in the
project except three main folders
which is controllers models and views
and as you would have guessed this is
what mvc stands for
which is model view and controller
that being said let's understand the
architecture of an
mvc application the first thing in
mvc is the model model represents the
shape of the data
a class in c sharp is used to describe a
model
the model component corresponds to all
the data related logic
that user works with this can represent
either the data that is being
transferred
between view and controller or any
business
logic related data model would also
represent all the tables of the database
so if you have 10 tables in the database
you will have
at least 10 models on top of that there
is also
more complexity but we will go into
those details
later on in the course so if a class is
a model
then all the properties in that class
will be all the columns of a table
so that is the simple relation that you
can think about
model right now then we have the view
view in an mvc is a user interface
view basically means whatever you see
when you click a web
page the ui that you see that will be
represented
by the view view in asp.net mvc
is html css and some special syntax
which is razer syntax so main thing
about
view is that it represents the user
interface logic
of your application finally we have the
controller
the controller handles the user request
typically whenever a request comes in
like user clicks anything
it will raise an http request which will
be handled by the controller
the controller then uses the model as
well as view
to process the request and then it
returns back
an appropriate response so controller
acts as an
interface between model and view to
process
all the business logic incoming requests
and
it manipulates the data using model
and interact with the view to render the
final
output this is just a brief overview of
how model
view and controller interacts so just to
summarize what happens
is first a user clicks something on the
website
so a request comes to controller
controller will always be the main entry
point in an mvc application and
in controller it will hit any of the
action methods that we have defined
inside the controller now controller
will uses
the model and it will fetch all the data
that it needs to display
in a view then it passes that data to
the view
so that view can render the final page
that user
can see then view will send the request
back to the controller
and then based on whatever is rendered a
response will be sent back
and user will be able to see the page
so you can see controller can be treated
as heart of your application
with that in place in the next video
let's run our application for the first
time
and see how model view and controller
interacts
and how routing works
now before i run the application and
show you routing in detail
let's take a look at the folders that we
have with model
views and controllers so right here
we have a home controller and in the
model
we have the error view model whenever
we'll be adding new models or if we want
to add a new table
in the database we will be adding models
inside this folder
controller as we know is the heart of
the application
in controller if you expand this you see
there are many of the functions
these are known as individual action
method
so a controller has action method if we
go back to the routing template that we
had
we had the controller name and the
action name
so what means is if someone calls index
then they can call it home
forward slash index and the control will
hit
this breakpoint when the url is
submitted
and once the control gets here we are
just returning back the view
so this view will be inside the views
folder
and inside the home folder the folder
name will match
exactly as the controller name so it
will look for an
index view inside the home folder inside
views
and that will correspond to the action
method that we see
right here so what we have in the index
view
is if you open it we have a title we
have welcome here
and then we have learned about building
web apps with asp.net core
let's run this and make sure that this
is actually working
so let's run our application for the
first time
and great we see that page is loaded
now right here in the url we do not see
any controller or action name
and the reason is if we go back to the
application in startup
we configured the default to home
controller index
action so that being said if you add a
debugging point
right here and if you go back and press
enter
you will see that it hits this
breakpoint so it is actually calling the
index
action method inside your home
controller
that being said let's continue here and
the view is loaded
now what will happen when we click
privacy
you can see in the url on the bottom
here it is going to home controller
and privacy action method so right here
inside home controller we have the
privacy action method
which just returns back a view that view
will again be inside views home
and we have the privacy view and this is
what we should see
when we click that let's go back and
click here
now you can see the control is getting
to the privacy
action method and if you hit continue
the privacy view will be loaded
great so we can see how routing is
working so far
right now we do not have any id even if
you add an id
it will still load the privacy because
id is
optional so if you have it or if you do
not
that doesn't matter so with this routing
is making
little bit more sense on how the
controllers
and view routing works one thing you
should always remember
is if your name is home controller you
should have a folder within the view
with the name home and in there you will
add
all the views corresponding to the
action methods
inside the home controller that being
said right here there are few more views
that i want to explain you
let me do that in the next video
in the last video we saw the routing and
we saw how the model
and views are integrated together that
being said
in the views we have a shared folder
this shared folder is used for partial
views
partial views are similar to user
components if you are coming from
classic c
sharp so it is basically a view
that you want to consume in multiple
places in your application
along with that we have a special
partial view which is underscored layout
underscore layout is the default master
page
for your application
so in here if we scroll back to the
project that we are running
we have the header here so the header
and footer are included
in underscore layout right here we have
the header
then we have render body and we have the
footer
along with that in underscored layout we
have some styling
and javascript that can be used
throughout the application
so in future if you want a styling or a
javascript functionality that you want
to use throughout the application
this is the place where you will add it
other than underscore layout
we have a partial view which is
validation scripts partial
this partial view just has the reference
to some of the jquery for validation
we will be using this in the future
videos
then we have error.cs hdml
and this is just a common error view
that we have in developer
mode so that's about the shared folder
views
we will be adding more partial views in
future
that being said inside the views folder
we also have two
important files first is the view
imports
the purpose of view imports.cs hdml file
is to provide a mechanism to make
directives
available to razer page globally so that
you don't have to add them to the pages
individually
so right here it is adding the tag
helpers
so with this all the default tag helpers
that asp.net core team provides
will be added to all of the razer pages
in your application
if you do not have this then you won't
be able to use tag helpers
in your project an example of tag
helpers can be seen in underscored
layout
if we expand the header right here you
see this tag
helpers asp area asp controller
asp action these are all the tag helpers
that make
the binding look like html language
but it does the binding with your c
sharp code
tag helpers is an idea that microsoft
team has adopted
from other languages after looking at
the success
like angular and react so
if in future if you add more custom tag
helpers
you can register them here and they will
be available for use throughout the
application
that being said we'll go to the next
file which is
view start the main purpose of viewstart
is to set values that all the other
views will have to use
if this view exists and it is under the
views folder
it enables us to set the property that
applies to
all the views in the system right here
a most common underscored layout view
will set some properties
the default one in mvc is the layout
page
however you can also do complex thing in
view start
for example you can say that for a
specific controller
you want to change the layout page you
can add if condition
check the controller name and do complex
logic
but we'll just leave it simple for now
so here we are defining the default
master page for the application
is underscore layout right here
so if you change this your master page
could be changed
using the layout property in view start
also what you can do is you can add a
view start inside the folder as well
and then that file will take precedence
so with that i believe we have covered
all the files that we have
when the project was created now this
has been a lengthy section
and it was mostly theoretical with very
little exposure to routing
and the project but this won't be the
same moving forward
moving forward everything will be hands
on
and we will be coding everything and
exploring
asp.net core in detail
so that being said let's get started
with everything
from the next video now that our project
is created
and we have an overview of all of the
files that comes by default
let's add our model now what is a model
model will represent a table that we
want in our database
so for our application we want to add a
table in our database
for category in there we will have three
columns
we'll have category id category name and
display order
as i told you before we will not be
touching the database directly
if we have to make any change to our
database or
even create the database we will be
doing that
from our code so for that what we will
do is first inside the models folder
here
we will right click and we will add a
new class file
and we will call this as category
inside category what are all the columns
that we want
all of those columns will be properties
of these class
so we can use the snippet prop and press
tab twice
then we have a property that is
generated
first we want the id which will be
category id
or i can call this as an id
in sql server for columns you can have
them as identity
an identity column will mean that you do
not have to pass those values
whenever you add a new record it
automatically
increments by 1 and creates that
but you only have id here how do you
tell the database or
entity framework code that this column
needs to be a primary key
and it needs to be identity for that
we have data annotations you can see
right here it is
inside system dot component model dot
data annotations
if you press enter here it automatically
adds that namespace
right here once you add data annotations
it tells entity framework
that this column needs to be an identity
column
and a primary key for our table
entity framework also has default so if
the name is id
or if the name is category followed by
id
then it automatically adds it as a key
entity
so even if you do not add this it will
be added by default
but i always like to be explicit about
it so that when someone sees our model
they can get a better idea using this
there are many more data annotations but
we won't go into those details right now
i want to start from all the basic and
then we'll go into the advanced concept
next what property we want we'll press
prop again
and tab twice next we want a string
and we will call this category name
you can call this category name or i'll
just go with the name
last property that we want is an integer
and let me call this display
order now we won't be using this but i'm
just adding a new property
so i can show that to you guys so now
what we have is we want to create a
category table
in the database and we want these three
columns
in that table but how do we do all that
let's take a look at that in the
upcoming videos
now we have created our first model
which is the category model
we need to push this model to our
database
but first we do not even have a database
for our project
so let's go to sql server management
studio
and right here let's connect to a server
now here one thing that you should
remember is the server
name i have dot right now but i can also
change it to local db ms sql local db
now for some this might be the server
name they are able to connect to
and for others it might be a dot i have
both of the options
so i can connect to a dot as well as i
can connect to the local db
msql local db great you can see
both of these options work for me
once you have that determine which of
the server you want to use
for our course we will be using the dot
so if you expand the databases we have
two databases you can expand this you
can take a look
but what we want is we want to add our
own database right here
so how do we do that for that we need to
add a connection string
in our rocky project so right here
whenever we have to add a connection
string we'll be going to
appsettings.json
this is the file where we will be adding
all of the secrets
or connection strings for our project
now once you move this to production you
can move this to appsecret.json
but for the course app settings.json is
a perfect location
now the next question is where do you
define connection
string in here for that right here
we need to create a connection strings
and we can assign it inside the
parentheses
now in here we need to give a name so i
will call this
default connection and then
within the double quotation we will
write the connection string
so right now we have server equal to
and i will use a dot here because that
is what we are using
next thing that we have is the database
name
so we'll say database and what name do
we want
i'll call this as rocky after that
we will set the trusted connection to
true
it will be trusted underscore connection
is equal to
true and then we will have the multiple
active result sets to be true
that's all we need for connection string
now what i'll do is i'll copy and paste
this one more time
i'll comment this out and instead of dot
here
i will paste local db ms equal local db
because this might be connection string
you want to use if you wanted the
different
server we'll go with the dot
now we have our connection string in
place
the next step will be using this
connection string to actually create the
database
let's take a look at that in the next
video
now we need to create our database and
we also have to push the category model
to the database
in order to do that we need a db context
in our project dbcontext is provided by
entity framework before we do that
right here let me add a new folder
and i'll call this as data
in here we will right click add a new
class file
and i will call this application db
context
or you can call this any other name
followed by a db
context now this is just a basic class
how do you make this class a db context
in order to do that this class will have
to implement
or inherit from the db context
right now that class does not exist if
you do control dot here
it will show you options to install
packages
so we need to include entity framework
core
in our project now there are multiple
ways to do that
first thing you can directly go here and
you can click find and install the
latest version
next way you can go to tools newbit
package manager
and you can install the package if you
know the name with the package manager
console
and if you don't know the exact name we
will go to manage
new kit packages for the solution
in here what we will do is we will go to
browse tab
and we will search for our package which
is entity framework core
once you hit enter here the first
package you see is microsoft dot
entity framework core now entity
framework code
will not be the only package that we
will need
we will also need the package for sql
server
because entity framework core needs a
database to work with
so that will be sql server so right here
if we search for sql server we will have
a package
microsoft dot entity framework core dot
sql server
so in order to install this package
we'll click the project name
and we will hit the install button
now if you are on the preview versions
make sure that when you created the
project
the version name for preview should
match exactly
like you created the project if you
created the project with preview 3
right here it should be the preview 3
that you should be installing
and not preview for that being said
we'll switch to what we have
once you make sure all of that is good
let's hit the install button
it asks us for the license we'll accept
this
and great package has been installed
we see the error with db context but we
will solve that later on
now if you go to dependencies packages
you see you have microsoft dot entity
framework core
dot sql server if you expand that
you have microsoft packages and if you
expand further
you see that microsoft dot entity
framework core is already installed
the reason is because the sql server is
dependent on entity framework core
that's why if you install only sql
server
entity framework core gets installed by
default
now that the package has been installed
if we close this
and if we go to our application db
context right here
you click there and you will hit ctrl
dot for intellisense
it says that you can now add using
statement
for microsoft dot entity framework core
so with that we have added entity
framework core in our project
that being said we need to add some
configuration here
we need to create a constructor so we
can type ctor
you can see it is a code snippet for
constructor
and we'll press tab twice in here since
we are implementing the db
context we need to pass the db context
options here and we need to configure
the application db
context class we'll call this as
options what we have to do is we need to
pass all of these
options to the base class for db context
now this will include connection string
as well
so we'll pass base and we'll use the
options
if you do not understand this do not
worry it's just some configuration that
you have to do
in order to use the db context
that's everything that we had to do to
create a db context
for our project right now things might
not be making complete sense to you
but just stick with me for few more
videos
and you'll see how easy and magical this
is
now the thing that is remaining is we
need to create our category table
in the database and we also have to
create our database
let's continue in the next video to
finish the last step of
our configuration now we have the
application dbcontext class
next what we want to do is we want to
create the category table to our
database
whenever you have to do that you will
come to the application db context
once you have created the model and here
we will create
properties to push them to database
so we'll do prop and this time the
property type will be db set
in here what is the class name which is
the entity
so the entity that we want to create to
the database
is category entity and what name do you
want to give to the table
inside the database i want to call it
the same name as category
now by default the convention is to name
it plural
like categories but i like to name them
same as the table name or the model in
our project
so that way we will be creating a table
with the category name in the database
this is all looking good and fancy but
how will this come together
for that we will be using our startup
class file
because we want to configure this db
context
to be used by our application when it
starts
and that configuration will always be
done in startup class file
so inside the startup class file where
we have the services
we will be adding a service for rdb
context
so here we have add db context
and in here you need to pass the entity
name
which is application db context
then we need to configure options on
that property
and if you see right here we are passing
those
options to db context so in startup
what are the options we want to
configure
first thing is we want options that we
want to use sql server
so right here you will have to add the
namespace microsoft dot
entity framework core and then you need
to configure the sql server
options now sql server options does not
need
many things it just needs a connection
string
and that connection string is inside app
settings.json
inside connection strings make sure that
you name this
exactly and there is no spelling mistake
or else this won't work
once you make sure both of them are
looking exactly like me
you'll come back to startup and we have
the configuration
object here on configuration object we
have an extension method
get connection string what this will do
is it will look into your app settings
and it will go inside connection strings
right here
in there what key should it search for
key will be the default connection
so we will copy this come back here
and inside double quotes we will paste
default connection
that way it will retrieve the connection
string and it will
pass it to the options for sql server
so that's all configuration we had to do
to add our db context
and use of sql server to our project
so with that we complete the
configuration that was needed
but right now the sql server does not
have our database
or the table for that we need to
understand
migrations whenever we will have to push
any change from our website to our
database we will be creating migrations
let's understand them in the next video
now we have added in our db context the
category model
so the next thing that we have to do is
we need to add a migration
to push that to the database in order to
add migration
we'll go to tools new get package
manager
and we will open up package manager
console
in here we will be adding our migration
so for that we will add a command add
migration
and then we will give our migration a
meaningful name
what are we doing in the first migration
we are adding the category table to
database
so we can say add category to database
and we will hit enter when you do that
you will see an
error message it says the term add
migration
is not recognized as a name of command
let function
script file or operable program
if you created your project with
individual users account identity
then you won't see this error because it
installs the new git package
that is needed for migration but since
we did not do that
we will have to install another nuget
package
so we'll go to the nuget package manager
and we will search for tools we want to
install
microsoft.entityframework.tools
right here this is entity framework core
tools for
new get package manager console in
visual studio
make sure you install the correct
version
and great everything looks good so we
will close this
and if we go back to our application db
context
let me open the package manager console
here
let's try to run this one more time in
order to run the same statement
you just press the up arrow the build
started
build succeeded and it added our
migration
now this is entity framework code doing
its magic
you can see what it's doing is it is
creating a table
called as category and it has three
columns
first is the id column which is of type
identity
and nullable is false then we have the
name
and display order and it also adds a
constraint
to make the x dot id as the primary key
so all of this magic is done by entity
framework core
it automatically converts your model
that you have
into migrations and then you can push
this migrations to the database
so how do you push them to database now
for that if you go to package manager
console
here let me clear this out and the next
command
is update database so once you have that
command
and if you press enter it will push all
the pending migrations to the database
in case like ours where the database
does not exist
it will first create the database and
then proceed further
now if you have any errors while
building the project
you won't be able to get past the step
because your project must build
successfully in order to proceed
so right here you can see it's done what
exactly just happened
let's understand that in the next video
now that we have pushed the migration
let's see what actually happened
in sql server in here we see the new
database which is rocky
let's expand that and we have the tables
now in tables you see we have created
category table
but entity framework code already added
underscore ef
migrations history here it keeps a track
of which migrations are
actually applied so that it can
synchronize
everything right now that will be just
the name of the first migration that we
added
which is add category to database
so we'll close this and then let's
examine the category table
it has the three columns that we wanted
so it actually pushed our category model
to the database
and everything is looking good right now
so remember whenever you have to make
changes you first make the changes
add a migration and then you update
database to push the migration to the
database
so that being said let's continue in the
next video
before we start with anything let's run
the application
so if we go in the arrow here with the
browser
you can pick which browser you want for
the application
i will be using the new microsoft edge
and let me run this and take a look at
the result
so our application is up and running and
we see home
and privacy what we want to do is we
want to add a new tab here
or we can replace the privacy tab with
category
how do we do that this navigation bar
that we have
is inside the shared folder inside views
so if we go to views shared we have the
underscored layout
and right here we have the home and
privacy here you can see the action name
is privacy
and the controller name is home
what we will be doing is for category we
will be adding a new controller
so for that we'll go to solution
explorer in controllers
we'll add a new controller in order to
do that
we will have to stop the application and
controllers add a new controller
and we will go with the empty controller
now what you need to do is we need to
name our controller
it should always end with the controller
keyword
so whatever is before that will be the
controller name
and we will call this category
controller
great so you can see our new controller
has been created
and in there we have an index action
method
how can we navigate to this controller
using our url
let's run the application
and then if we want to go to the privacy
action in home controller
you can see the url is home followed by
privacy
so in order to go to our category it
will be category controller
and what is the action name that is the
index action name
but if you press enter right now you
will see an error
that view index was not found that is
because we have added the action here
but we have not added the view
so inside layout what we will do is
change this to category controller
action we'll change this to index
and we will call this category
if you go back and if you refresh the
home page
let's go here this time the privacy will
be updated to category
but if you click on category you will
still see that edit message
let's continue in the next video to fix
this error message
and add our view
now if we try to navigate to category
controller
index action the view is not found so
let's add that view for that it is
simple
you can do one of the two things first
is inside views you can create a new
folder
with the exact name as the controller
name which is category
it won't be category controller it will
be only category
and then in there you can right click
add a new view here
and that will do the trick or simple way
go to category controller right click on
the action method
select add view we will be using the
razer view
do not go with the empty option here
and then you can see here we have some
configuration
first is the view name which will keep
the same as
index next you can use template when you
create a view
it can be create template edit details
or delete
we will be going with the empty template
and we don't want any model classes
right now if you select any of the other
then you have to select the model class
like if you want to create
what object should it create should it
create a new category
if yes what should be the db context
that should be used
but if you go with empty you don't get
those options
that being said we have not used partial
views right now
so we'll leave this unchecked and option
here
is use a layout page if you check this
and if you leave this
empty it will use the default layout
that you have
so we'll just keep that and press the
add button
it will add few neoget packages for
scaffolding
and then it will create the index view
one thing to notice is the view will be
added inside a folder name
with the exact name as your controller
which is category
that being said if you run the
application now and if you hit
the category you will see the page with
the word
index in there so if you hit category
great you can see the view is being
rendered
so now that our view is added and our
database is in place
let's see how we can create a category
let's continue working on the index page
in the next video
what do we want to do on the index page
of category
we want to display all of the categories
that exist
in our database right now we do not have
any categories in our database but
let's say we add some categories
manually for
our testing so we can go to database
edit top 200 rows and we'll just give it
a test name
display order one will give it test to
display order two we have two categories
now
so if you do select star here you will
see two records
let's see how we can display them here
in order to display them
we need to extract these values from the
database
so for that we'll be using entity
framework
and we need the application db context
or the db context to do that
so we'll go to the category controller
and in here
we need an object of application db
context
but thankfully dependence injection
takes care of all of that
so right here we'll just use application
db
context and we'll get that using
dependency injection
so right here we will be adding a
private read-only property
and this will be for application db
context
we'll call this underscore db now we
need to populate this property
and we'll do that with constructor and
we'll be using dependency injection
if you go to your startup cs right here
you have added the db context
so you have already added that in your
service container
if you want to pull something from that
container in the constructor
you just write the class or the
interface name
so this one is application db context
and we'll call this db what this object
will have
is it will have an instance of the db
context
that dependency injection would create
and pass it to you in your constructor
you do not have to worry about all the
backend behind that
asp.net core takes care of everything
so you can just assign your local
underscore db
as the db object that is passed and then
you can use this underscore db
throughout your controller so we have
the database object in underscore db
what if we want to retrieve list of all
of the category
so in the index let's retrieve an i
enumerable
of category and let me call this object
list obj list is equal to how do we
retrieve that from database
we will be using entity framework so we
have the database object
and in there you already see category if
you just do like that it will retrieve
all of the categories from your database
and it will store them
in this obj list let me copy
paste it to the view and will return
that list
to be displayed in our view let's add a
debugger and see if it actually passes
anything
let's run the application
and let's hit category it will hit our
debugging breakpoint
and right now the list should be empty
here that's good
if we press f10 to continue to the next
line
if you hover now you see the list and
result view
it should have two values and these are
the two categories that we added
so you can see how easy it was we did
not have to write a query like select
star from category
entity framework core takes care of
everything
just one line and you get all of the
categories
so even though we spend some time in
configuration for entity framework and
db set
and db context you can see the advantage
that it brings to the table
and in future this will save tremendous
amount of time
as we will see so now we have list of
all the categories
and we are passing that to the view
if you hit continue here you will see
that we do not see any of the list
that's because if we go to the index
view we are not fetching that model
or we are displaying anything in here
other than index
let's do that in the next video
now we want to display all of the
categories in our view
so we are already passing that from our
controller
when we return to the view whenever you
pass anything from the controller
you need to make sure that you fetch it
inside your view
now how do you tell this view that
actually a list of categories is going
to be passed to you from the controller
for that we will define at model on the
top here
in here m will be of lower case
and then we will define what will be the
model type
here it's an enumerable of category
so we'll say it's an i enumerable of
category
if you type just category this works but
what i prefer is i
prefer rocky dot models
dot category this way you know the
complete path for the category
so in large scale application you are
not confused
now what will happen is the list that we
will pass from here
will be available on this view and we
can display that so we can use
some bootstrap styling and we can
display a table
we can add a div give it a class of
container
and we'll give padding 3 in here then we
can add a div give it a class of
row and padding top we'll give it four
and in there we'll add a div give it
class of column six
we'll divide it in two parts we'll have
another
div class of column six
in the first one here we will have an h2
tag
and we'll give it a class of text
primary
and we'll call this as category list
in here we want to display a link to
create
new category that looks good
then let me add some line here and then
i'll display a table
now the table i only want to display if
there are more than one categories that
have to be displayed
so with razer syntax you can combine c
sharp syntax
with the html for that you just write
the add sign
and then here we have the for loop we
have for
each loop you can see and we also have
if conditions so we can use the c
sharp if condition and we want to see if
this has more than one category
here the model was lower case but
whenever
anywhere else in the view if you want to
access this model
it will be a capital m so it will be
model dot we just want the count on that
if it is greater than zero that means
that category exists
so if the category exists we want to
display a table
and we can use bootstrap classes for
table
table bordered and table striped
we can also give it a style of width of
100 percent
inside here we have the t-head and we
have the table
row in which we'll have the header
first one let me display category name
followed by display order
and we'll have an empty th so this looks
good for the heading
then we have the t body in body
let's say you have 10 category so you
want a loop that is iterated 10 times
and you display all of the properties
so like we had the if with the razor we
also have for
each and we'll iterate through all the
categories
so we'll say variable object in
model now what is model model is
actually the i enumerable or list of
category
so right here we will add a tr tag
and we'll display td we'll give it a
width
of 50 percent the first thing here is
the category name
so at obj dot we have
the name in there we'll copy this
paste it one more time we'll give it
thirty percent
and we can display the display order
and then in the last one here td
let's say we want to display the buttons
to edit or delete
a category but we'll do that one thing
at a time
then we have the if condition so we can
add
else block and we can just display in
paragraph
no category exists
so this looks good let's run our
application
and see how things look like
we'll go to category and we'll continue
on our debugger
great we see both of the categories here
we have the create new category so we'll
make this a button or a link
and we'll continue working on this in
the next video
now we have worked on our index page and
we are loading
all of the page for that what were the
two things that were needed
one was the controller action method
inside category controller
and we needed a corresponding view
what we want to do is we want to create
a new page for
creating a new category so for that the
first thing that we'll do
is we'll need a new action method right
here
so we can copy this and paste it one
more time
and this will be for create
what happens in the create in create we
will display them
two empty text box to enter the name and
display order
for the new category they want to create
that being said since everything will be
empty we do not even have to pass
anything to the view
it can be empty so this
make sure that this is get for
create once we have added the controller
let's add the view as well it will be
the razer view
and we'll keep it the same let's add
this
first thing that you do whenever you add
any view is
will that be a model needed for this
view
we are not passing anything from the
controller
but that doesn't mean we won't be using
a model in the view here
we will be using model which will be
category so we'll go to
rocky.models.category
now why do we need a model here and the
reason we need
model here is whenever user enters
any of the category name and display
order and hits the create button
we want to pass those values to our
action method
which will be a post action method for
category
and we want to create the category
so here what we'll do is we'll add a
form and it will have a method of
post and where it should post
we can explicitly define that using tag
helpers
tag helpers looks exactly like html
but they are asp dash and then these are
the default tag helpers that
asp team provides so right here you can
see there is a tag helper called
asp action we will call this as create
this means that when the form executes a
post method
it should look for a post action method
of create
we will add that in the next video but i
wanted to point that out
in here we'll use some bootstrap classes
of border
and padding three and in here
we'll add div give it a class of form
group
and row and we'll add the heading here
h2 give it a class of text info
and we'll give padding left of three
we'll call this add category
now that we have that let's run this
application and see this title
if we go to category and we'll remove
this debugging point
right now we do not have the button to
navigate to the create new category
so let's do that in the index right here
we have the create new category how do
we navigate to that page
in order to go to that page you will
have to go to the action method
which is create inside the category
controller
thankfully we have tag helpers for that
so right here inside the anchor tag
we have the asp action tag helper
what action do we want to redirect to
we want to redirect to the create action
and that is inside the controller which
is the category controller
typically you would write the controller
name
before the action name that's how the
navigation goes
first what controller in that controller
what is the action method once you have
that
you'll close the anchor tag after the
create new category
let's go back and refresh here and if
you click here
it takes you to your ad category
let's add a little bit of styling here
so we'll add a class of btn
btn primary and let's see how this looks
okay we'll also align this to right
so we have text right and perfect
so when you hit on create new category
it takes you to the add category
let's continue working on add category
in the next video
now we want to add the text boxes for
adding a new category options like name
and display order
so we'll go back to our project and
let's stop this
now we will be doing that inside create
we will be adding
little bit of more bootstrap styling
i don't want to spend much time on
bootstrap styling
so i will be attaching snippets with the
course
where you can get them and paste those
bootstrap directly here
in section 1 i have lecture project
resources
in which i explain how you can get all
the snippets
so right here we are on section 2 but if
you go back
you will have all the section so we will
open up the add category snippet
and we'll copy this go back to the
create
and make sure you add this after this
form group and row
and paste it here you can see it's not
doing anything fancy
if you save this and run the application
you will see what exactly was done
so if we go to category here and we go
to create new
create uc name display order and here we
need text boxes
and we'll create two buttons one button
to go back
to the previous page and one button to
create or add a category
so let's switch back here we want to
display
name so rather than using just
name we can use tag helpers so we have a
label
in there we have asp4 tag helper
and here you will see all the properties
in your model
like name you can also add a class if
you want but
i'll keep it simple what is the
advantage of using this tag helper
rather than typing just name
let me also add a display order here
and we'll save this if you go back and
refresh
there you go not much difference the
advantage that this tag helper brings
is if we open up our category model
right here you can use data annotations
to display something
else like here if you go back display
order is one word
what if you want a space in them for
that we have data annotations
so right here we have display name
and here we'll say display order
once you do that and if you run the
application
this time it will use whatever we gave
as
display name because we are using the
tag helper
so if you go to create new category now
you see a space between
so that way inside your model you can
define
what display name you want and there are
many more data annotations which we will
take a look
in the upcoming videos so now
you saw one advantage that you have with
the tag helpers
that being said we also have tag helpers
for input
as well so in the input tag here
we will use the tag helper which is asp4
this input is for the name and we can
give it a class of form control to take
full width
let's go back and refresh here and great
we have a text box let me switch back to
the application
and do the same for display order
if you refresh perfect we have two nice
looking text boxes
let's also add buttons so we'll go back
and here we can do an input of type
submit or you can just add a button here
then we'll add bootstrap classes btn btn
info and width of 100 percent
let's call this create
and we need a value will be create
after that for back button we can add a
link here
and we can copy the link that we have in
index
and we'll paste it here when we want to
go back
we do not need the controller name the
action name that we want to go to
is the index action to display all the
categories
and here we can just display back
if you save this and refresh great we
have create and back
and i make this as success and
width of 100 so we have two buttons now
if you click back it takes you back to
the category
one thing you notice here is you do not
need the category name
that name is optional because you are
dealing with
views in the same category if you had to
go to the page or view that belongs to a
different controller
then you need to explicitly define the
controller name here
by default it assumes you mean the same
controller
that you are in right now so with this
our page is looking in a good form
when we see the add category let's
continue in the next video
this time what we want is when we enter
anything here
and hit the create button it should add
a new category to database
so for that if we go back to our
application you can see we have
input type of submit and then we have a
form here
which goes to the post of create
so if we go to category controller we
need to add that
we can copy the get for create paste it
here
but this time we need a post for create
now inside the post right here we will
get a category object
that we have to add to the database
with post what you should do is you have
to define that this is actually a post
action method
so you'll add an attribute http post
and we will be using validate
anti-forgery token
validate anti-forgery token is a
built-in mechanism with the forms
in which it appends an anti-forgery
token and on the post you validate
that that token is still valid and the
security has not been tampered
so we get that built-in security so
we'll use that in all of the post action
methods
now here you will receive the object
that you have to add to the database
adding to database is simple you need to
access the db
context db on category you have the add
method
provided by entity framework core
on there you can see it expects a
category entity
so we'll pass the object and then at
this step it will not add the category
to database if you want to add it you
have to call save changes
and then it makes the database call on
line 41
once it adds the category what we want
to do
we can just go back to this index and
display all the categories
so rather than returning back to a view
we want to return
redirect to an action method and what
action method do we want to redirect to
we want to redirect to this index action
since it is in the same controller we do
not have to define the controller name
here
let's give this a try and see how things
look
let's go back and add a debugger right
here
and let's go to category add a new
category
we'll try to add this we hit
our debugging point and inside the
object here
you see we have the display order as
well as name which is valid
how did it automatically bind this and
passed it here
the reason is if you go to the create
you used
tag helpers for input since we used asp4
it automatically knew that whatever was
being entered
in this text box it has to bind that to
the name
property of the model which is category
and on the post it passes that to
our controller right here
so if you do f10 you execute the add
statement
if you go back to the database and you
execute here it has not been executed
if you run the save changes and if you
go back
now you'll see three records
so you can see it actually executes on
save changes
let's hit continue and now we see the
three categories
great so with this you can see that how
we can create
a new category and we implemented the
post action method
for create everything looks good right
now
but what if we want some validations
let's take a look at that in the next
video
before we move on to validations let's
practice what we have learned so far
with an assignment
in this assignment i want you to create
an application type
model in that model we will have two
properties
id and name we created the category
model with
more properties so this should be
somewhat similar to that
once you create the model then you have
to push that model to the database
so that a table can be created for that
model
once you are able to successfully create
the table inside the database
then you should work on creating an
application
type controller so the name of the
controller should be
application type and in there you have
to implement the index
and create functionality that we did
with controllers so far
so it is exactly following the steps
that we did
but for a different model so good luck
with the assignment
and this will give you practice to
understand what we have been
implementing
so far now in this video
let's work on the solution for the
assignment
i hope you were able to do all the three
points that were here
let's start with the first one in which
we have to create the model
for application type and push that to
the database
we'll switch back to the application and
in here
we'll close everything that we have
close all tabs
let's go to solution explorer and we
have our models
right here we can copy the category
model and paste it one more time
here and we'll change the name to
application type
we will copy the name and we'll paste it
here
now we need properties inside the
application type
which is id and name we do not want the
display order
you can remove the key data annotation
if you want but i'll just leave it here
once you add the model you need to add
this to database
so for that what you have to do is you
need to go to data
application db context and we need to
create a db set
for application type
we will call this application type and
we won't use the plural notation
once you save this you have to add the
migration
so tools you get package manager we'll
go to the console
and here let me clear this and we'll add
a new migration
we'll call this at application type to
database
great so migration has been added and
right here if you see it is adding the
two columns
id and name and it has a primary key
on the id column this looks good
let's update the database
i'll increase the size here there we go
and perfect database has been updated
let's go to sql server to validate them
we'll refresh here and we have the
application type
if we expand this we have two columns
so perfect our first task from the
assignment has been completed
in which we had to create the
application type model
and we had to push that to the database
next thing that we have to do is we need
to create the application type
controller
so let's switch back again and we have
the controllers
i can just copy the category controller
and paste it one more time i'll change
the name to application type
now i hope you did not do the copy and
paste and you created from scratch
i do not want to spend time there so
i'll just make the changes
we'll change the names here we need
application db context
right here this will be of application
type and
this will be application type as well
we'll retrieve the application type
object
and we'll add that right
here sweet so here it will be
application type
and that looks good final thing that you
have to do is you need to add the views
as well
so what we can do is we'll just go here
and we have the views which is category
we can just copy this and paste this one
more time
we'll change the name to application
type whoops we have a spelling mistake
there
there we go and we'll change the create
the model will be application type
in there we do not need display order
we'll remove that
everything else looks good in the index
we do not need the display order and we
do not need the controller
only the action name is sufficient
and this will be application type
great we'll just have the name here and
we do not need display order
great
now let's give this a test we'll go to
solution explorer
inside layout we need to add another
link
for application type here so we'll call
this
application type controller
and perfect let's run our application
and take a look at if we are able to
create
any new application type on the nav bar
we have application type now we run into
an
editor here and i think that's in the
application type controller
we are passing application type list
in the index we have category you can
see the class is application type
so this will be application type as well
so you can see if the model here is
different
then what you pass from the controller
you will get an
error message then we'll hit the refresh
button
and this should load perfect
we have the category list here so we'll
change that
to application
type list great let's create a new
application
here also we have the category so inside
create for application type
we'll change the heading to add
application type
and refresh let's try to add a new
application
and great it's working as expected
so that was the quick assignment that we
did
next thing we'll be working again on the
category
but before we work on the edit or delete
functionality for category
i want to show you validations that we
have to implement
in category so let's take a look at that
in the next video now
in the last video we had some practice
with application type
let's switch back our focus to category
and
in here let's add some validation
we want a validation that name should be
a required field
and display order should be greater than
zero
how do we actually implement those
validation
now you can always use custom javascript
to check what was entered
and display alert message but with
asp.net cool
you get validations right out of the box
in order to implement validations we
again have data annotations
in order to check that out let's switch
back to the application
and we did not have to rerun it let me
stop that
what we will do is we'll open up the
category model
we'll close everything else and we'll
open up the category model
here we have attributes like key display
name
similarly we have requirements for
validation
so on name we just add a required
attribute
before that property then the display
order
will make sure that this is required as
well and with display order
we want it to be greater than zero for
that
we have range with range you have to
define the minimum
which is 1 and what is the maximum
so we can just say int dot max value
could be the maximum
and then for the third property here you
can define
an error message default editor message
if you don't like it
you can always provide a custom error
message
so here we can just display display
order
for category must be greater than
zero once you add this how do you
actually
implement these validations inside your
view
let's take a look at that by going to
our view
so for category we have to create view
here we have tag helpers for validation
as well
what we need to do is on the top here we
first need a div
and we'll use asp validation summary it
has multiple properties
all model only and none let's keep it to
model only for now
and we'll add a class of text danger to
display it
in red that being said where we have the
individual properties
in those places let's add a span and
in there we have another tag helper asp
validation 4.
in this pane we will display if any
error messages
are for the name property
so in here we'll define name here and
we'll give it a class
of text danger we will copy this
and we'll do the same for display order
so let me add that here once you do this
and if you run the application
you won't see the change because you are
not right now validating it
now validations you can do it on server
side
or on the client side let me show you
first how to do the validations
on the server side so server side we
have the controller for category
so we'll open up the category controller
and
before we actually add a category we
want to validate
we already have the validations inside
the category model
so asp.net core has a method here
which is model state dot is valid
this actually checks if all of the rules
that you have defined in your model
are those valid if those are valid only
then it will go inside the if condition
so only if it is valid we'll paste it
to add the new category and return to
the index
if it is not valid we just want to
return
back to the view so that we can display
the error
message now when we return back to the
view
we can pass the object right here so
that we can have those values
let's see this in action so let's run
the application
and let me add a debugger and let me add
a debugger
once we do that let's continue in the
next video
now that we have added the debugger let
me switch back to the application
and let's go to category this time
if we try to create a new category and
hit it with the empty record
you see it goes back and it hits our
breakpoint
here we have to debug the model state
so if we go on model state let's first
examine the
is valid you can see it's false
now what properties are invalid so if
you hover on model state
expand this go to result view you see
both the properties
and both of the validations are invalid
so if it's invalid you'll continue it
will return back to the view
and it displays the error message
okay so that looks good let's say we add
some value here
and the display order will make it zero
display order if you remember we have
validation that it should be greater
than zero
if you hit create again that is valid is
still false
this time if you examine what properties
are not valid
it's only display order the name is now
valid
so you can see how validations are
working
and now you see your custom error
message that we
implemented so with this we saw server
side validation
if you change this to something valid
now and if you try to create
it should be successful you can see it
was created
and we have the same test with display
order too
now we have the server side validations
but what if we want to do the
validations on client side
to avoid a round trip implementing those
is simple as well you will just go back
to your create
and right here at the end we will add a
section
for scripts here you can add any of the
javascript
if you take a look at the solution
inside the shared we have validation
scripts
partial we need to use this inside the
section here
and it will do the client-side
validations automatically
so here we will use the tag helper in
which we have
partial we'll give it a name of
underscore validation scripts
partial make sure that the name is
exactly as you see
right here with that in place if you
save this
and if you refresh the application
if you try to hit the create button you
see the error message directly here
without making a round trip if you go
back
we still have our debugger in model
state dot
is valid but it doesn't even hit there
and it displays the error message as
soon as you change it
so it's not hitting our server and the
validations
are being done on client side now so
with this we have seen how we can
implement
client-side validations and server side
validations
i want to show you one more thing if you
switch back to the create
in the validation summary we have model
only
if we make it all and if we go back and
refresh the page
let's try to hit the create button now
you see two things
where we have the validation summary it
displays
all of the error message and then in the
model
it displays the corresponding so if you
have model
only in that place it was only
displaying the error message
where you have the asp validation for
so those are the two things that i
wanted to show you
with all and model only so we'll save it
and we'll just use model only even if
you comment this line out
and if you go back and hit create it
still acts the same
but i wanted to point out the changes so
i added the validation summary
but in future just validation for will
be sufficient
and for client-side we need to include
validation scripts partial
so that being said we have completed the
validations
for category now we need to add two more
buttons here
first button will be to edit a category
and the next one will be to delete a
category
so let me switch back to the application
stop it here
and we'll go to the category index right
here
if we scroll down here where we have
the td that is empty here we will be
adding
buttons so we can just add a class
of text center here and we'll give a div
give it a class of w 75 percent
and will make it button group
we can also add a row of group here
and i want to add two anchor tag
we have an anchor tag on the top so we
can just copy this
and paste it right here two times
first one here will be for edit and the
later one
is for deleting a category now we need
action names for edit and delete
so we'll call them edit as well as
delete we have not added these actions
but we will do that in a while so we
have vtn primary
and for delete we'll make it danger to
give it a red color
now think about whenever we have to edit
or delete a category
what is one thing that we will need the
one thing that we'll need
is the category id that user wants to
delete
so how will we pass that id when this
link will be clicked
asp.net core also has a tag helper for
that
which is asb route hyphen and then
you need to pass the id or the name that
you want to give to that parameter
we will just call it id and here we need
to pass the id
that we want to retrieve in the action
method
so that we can access using this obj
so we'll pass obj dot we should see all
of the properties
and we want to pass the id of the
category here
so we'll copy this and we'll paste it
in edit as well with that in place
let's run our application and make sure
the buttons are displaying
we do not have the action so if you
click it will just give us an error
message
so right here we go to category
and we have the edit and delete
i also want to add some margin here so
where we have the classes right here
i'll do
margin x2
okay and this looks much better
so now if you hover on the edit you can
see the id is appended in the url
and also if you go on delete you will
see the same things
if you click we have the url but we do
not have that page
or action method so let's add those
action methods
in the next video in this video
we want to work on category controller
and we want to add the edit
and delete action now in edit
and delete both of them we are passing
the id
so if we go to category controller we
can copy the get for create
and paste it right here we'll call it
get for edit and we'll call this
as edit as well in here
we will be receiving an id because that
is what we are passing
from the asp route id right here
so we'll receive an id and based on that
id
we need to retrieve that category from
the database
and we need to display that to the user
so here we will first check if id is
equal equal to now let's make it a
nullable field
or we can say if id is equal equal to
zero
if it is any one of these scenarios we
will just return back
not found because that is invalid
if that is not the case we want to
retrieve the category from the database
now we will be using the db context in
there we have category
this will retrieve all of the categories
but we just want the one category where
id
matches the id that we receive in the
parameter
so for that ef code provides a find
method
in which you need to pass the id
here the find method works only on
primary key
so if you pass the primary key of
category it will go through that column
and pick a record whose primary key
matches what we pass here
which is the id after we get that
we can check here if object is null
this means record was not found and we
can return back not found again
if it finds the record let's pass the
record to the view
so that we can display it so
this looks good let me add the view
we'll go with the razer view and let's
add this
edit will look exactly similar to what
we have for create
but the only difference is values will
be populated
let's go to the create for category copy
everything
close this and paste it right here
rather than action which is create we
can just
remove this from form the reason i was
able to remove that
is we are in edit and the post action is
also the same name as edit
so in that case it is an optional field
if it was something else then you should
define what action it should post
to since it is same we can remove that
we do not need the validation summary
rather than
add we will display edit category here
we'll scroll down in the value create
we will just display update
with that in place let's run this
application
and give edit a try
so we'll go to category we should have
two buttons edit and delete
let's click on edit great you can see
the name
as well as display order was populated
by default
so next thing that we want to do is when
we hit this update
these values should be updated in the
database
let's work on that in the next video
now we need to implement the update
functionality
so we'll close the application here and
we'll go to category controller
we can copy the post action method for
create
and paste it for edit we'll call this
edit and the object that it should
receive
should be category and we just need to
change the name here
to edit then when we are adding a
category
rather than add we should add the update
here
and then we'll save the changes redirect
back
and everything looks good now this will
work for
category but if you have complex object
where within category you have other
objects and everything
here you will face an error the reason
is if you go back to your edit right
here we are using
name and display order so when we'll be
posting we'll be getting those two
values
but what about the id we have not used
it anywhere here
because of which the id will be zero
so what is recommended is right here
we'll have an
input field we'll use asp4 which is the
id
and then we'll have it in a hidden field
that way when we post the form in the
object
we have the id as well the update will
only work if there is an
id associated because based on that it
finds out which entity or which category
it has to update in the database
that being said let's run this
application
and give that a try
so if we go to category and if we try to
edit the test
with display order one two five five
five
update great you can see it has been
updated
successfully also in edit if you remove
this and hit update
we get the error message and everything
is working
as expected last thing that is remaining
is the delete functionality let's take a
look at that
in the next video
now what we want to work on is the
delete functionality
so the delete page will look somewhat
similar to edit page
the difference is these things will not
be editable at all
and will have a delete button so let's
go back to our application
and we can copy the edit we'll paste it
for delete in delete as well we are
getting the id
that user wants to delete so we'll call
this delete
and this will be delete as well now with
delete we do not want the complete
object all we care about is the id
so we are just getting the id and that
should do the trick
but when we do that we get some other
error message
with the delete the reason is we have
two methods here
with the same parameters previously we
had the category object
so this was fine how do we fix this
we can change the name to something like
delete confirmed
or delete host but in the view we want
the name as delete and that will take
care of this error
that being said rather than update we
will have to use the remove method on
there
but we need the object so we can
retrieve that object
using this method here we'll paste it
here
and we'll find it based on the id pass
it to remove
save the changes redirect back to action
this looks good for the delete post and
delete cat will be exactly same as
edit get because we need to retrieve the
category
and pass it to the view now with delete
we don't care about the model state
because there won't be validation
the only check if you want to add is the
object
if this is null then we do not have
anything to delete
and we'll just return not found
else we'll just remove the entity that
we found and redirect back to the index
action so this looks good
next we need to add the view so inside
category
we can copy the edit and paste it one
more time
we'll call this delete and the model
will be same
rather than edit category this will be
delete category
then we want to display the name but we
do not need any validations
and we'll make them disabled so the user
cannot edit them with the button we'll
call this
as delete and the class will be danger
to display a red color perfect so
everything looks good let's run this and
give this a try
once we know the basic foundations of
one crud
operations now you will see the pattern
and everything will start to make much
more sense
when we go to category let's try to
delete
as soon as you try to hit the delete
button nothing happens
what is the reason the reason is simple
right here if you go to the controller
the name is delete post
so what you can do is we'll copy this
and we can go to the delete.cs html
in the form method we can write the asp
action and we can say delete post
since it is not the same name as delete
you do that you refresh the application
and you hit the delete button it works
now
so you can see one workaround when the
action name is not same
you can explicitly specify what action
should be called
on the post action method for this form
so with this we have completed the
credit operations on category
now that we have completed the grud
operations on category
i want to add font awesome in my website
so we'll go to font awesome here here
we have the font awesome let's go there
and let's hit on the start and we'll get
started
here we'll hit the download and the
download begins once it finishes
we'll open this up and extract it
so i'll extract this and we'll close it
here
we'll go to our snippets folder because
that is where i extracted
and we have the font awesome right here
what i will do is i will copy everything
that we have here
and we'll switch back to our solution
we'll right click on ww root folder and
open
in folder explorer here what i will do
is i'll add a new folder for
font awesome and i paste everything that
we copied
great so we have copied everything here
how do we use font
awesome now using that is simple
we'll just go back and we have to add
that
in underscore layout we have the css
here
we'll add a link rel of stylesheet
and we'll add an href up we'll point to
the css
here the intellisense is not working let
me stop the application
and we will add that path so right here
inside wwe root we have font awesome css
and all dot css let me pin this
with that in place font awesome is added
to our website
now how do we use the icons let's run
the application
and see we don't see any error message
and next thing we'll start using the
icons
we'll go to category and let me add a
plus sign
right here with the create new category
so we'll go to the index
and let me go to font awesome again
and we'll search for plus sign
[Music]
you go here and you'll copy this
will go back in the index where we have
create
we'll paste it and we'll add a space
we'll save that go back and refresh
not this there we go this should add a
plus sign
right here great you can see font
awesome is working
let me add icons for edit and delete
so if we go here and if we search for
edit
we have the first icon i'll just use
that copy it
go back to the application we'll paste
it here
and then we'll do the delete icon
copy this and just paste it right here
next i won't go back i'll just use the
sign out icon for that
we'll copy this and we'll go back to
edit we have the back right here
we'll paste it i'll do the same in
delete as well
and we have to create so let me go
to the views we have to create
and we'll scroll down
let's go back to the application and see
if everything now
looks good great we have edit and delete
and then if we go on create new we have
the back icon
and perfect everything looks good
now here rather than displaying edit
delete and everything
i'll just have the icon and i'll remove
the text
this is self-explanatory so we'll leave
it at that
so with this we have completed adding
font awesome to our project
and all the crud operations with the
category is working
next it's time to replicate the pending
things that we have
for application type in the next
assignment
things are moving along great and we are
making good progress
next thing for our assignment is we need
to add the required validation
for the application type name and we
want to do that on both client side
and server side along with that
we need to perform edit and delete
functionality with application type
this is exactly what we did with
category so you should not face
any issue so good luck with the
assignment
and in the next video i'll do the same
to provide the solution
so we need to do two functionalities
first we need to add the validation
so let me switch back and we need to
work with application type model
so right here we need to add the
required
and that will take care of making it a
required property
once you make this change then we need
to add the validation summary
so we'll close everything that we have
here
we'll save this and close it as well now
we need to open up the category for
create
and we have the validation for we can
just copy this
we'll go back inside our application
type
we have create we'll paste it right
after the input tag
if you open up the create here and if
you just copy
everything that you see here and we'll
just
paste it we'll make sure this is for
application type
right here changing things will be much
simple
we just need application type
add application type name looks good
we do not want the display order and
buttons looks good
yep so everything is looking good right
here
next thing is we want to also modify the
index
for application type so we can just copy
things that we have
inside this td we'll go back here
and we'll paste it right here
the controller name you can either
change this to application type
or you can remove it because it is
within the same controller
once you do that changes inside the
index
it's time to go to the controller for
application type
and category here we will be dealing
with only create
but in future we have to perform edit
and delete as well
so why not just copy everything that we
have in category controller
we'll copy this paste it inside the
application type controller
right here we'll scroll up we'll copy
the name
application type controller
and we'll just delete this we'll paste
it here
there we go and we'll change to
application
type we can change things one by one
but rather than doing that i would
prefer doing the bulk change
there we go
so what we did is we updated everything
that we did for category
with application type if we build our
project
we shouldn't see any error message
now we have also added model state
inside the post
so let's give that a try one last thing
we'll close the index in the create is
if we go to the create for category
and application type we have the
validation scripts
partial for the client-side validation
so let's give that a try and see if our
validations are working
an application type will create
and great it's working if we try to edit
this
the edit view was not found so let's add
edit view
and delete view and we'll add a plus
sign on the index
so we go to the index of category we
have the plus sign here
we'll copy that and we'll paste that
in the index for application type
next we want to edit and delete we can
copy these
paste it inside the application type
and we'll modify them first thing will
be the model
which is application type and we do not
want the display order
i believe that's all that we had to
change the action name is delete post
and we have the delete post and
application type
yep we double check that next we have
the edit
so we'll change that to application type
edit application type and we do not need
the display order
this looks good in delete
we'll change it to delete application
type
let's run our application and with this
everything should be done
for our assignment now again i have been
copying and pasting everything but i
hope you do these things from scratch
so that you get more exposure to what we
just did
let's try to edit this and that's
working
if we delete great everything is working
as expected
all the crud operations are working now
with
all the validations if you are
interested in the full course
you can view the details on
on.netmastery.com
but i do not like to leave things at
this
i want to show you one important step in
any web application
which is deployment right now our
application is a basic
grud web application but still we can
deploy
our application so in order to do that
we'll have to go to azure portal
here you can sign up for your account
you can get a free account for 12 months
i already have my account so i will log
in
and rather than sign up it will show me
i already have an existing subscription
so i'll log in there and we are on our
portal
you can see i have 200 dollars of
remaining credit
that you get when you sign up for the
first time
in here whenever you have to deploy
anything you create a resource group
then in that resource group we will have
to create an app service to host our
website
and we will need a database to actually
insert all of the data we can do
everything in the portal or we can
switch back to visual studio
and in here if we go on rocky let's
right click here
and we will select publish that will
show us all the options that we have to
configure
we will select azure here we'll select
the windows service
then you have to make sure you sign in
to your account if you are not signed in
so in here we will be creating a new
azure app service
i'll call the application name as rocky
crud
and i already have an azure subscription
which is the free subscription
then we have to select the resource
group
if you are here for the first time you
will just have to create a new resource
group
and you'll have to provide a name i
already have a group
so i will use that after that we need to
select the hosting plan
we can create a new hosting plan here
and i'll call this rocky crud plan for
size i will use the free one
we will create this and that will
configure
in the existing resource group for my
case
it will create a new hosting plan for
our crud application
we'll wait for it to get done
once it completes in here you see
deployment slots
we are not working with slots but in
production application
if you have multiple feature sites you
can use deployment slots here
let's click finish and once you do that
it will show you some of the service
dependencies
like it says sql server database
so we will configure the sql server
database right here
we will select the azure sql database
and we'll create a new sql database
i'll call the name as rocky crud db
and we can select any of the existing
server
or i can always create a new server
we'll keep the default location and for
the admin username
you cannot use admin so i'll use admin
user
and password i'm gonna use admin
star with a capital a
so we'll use that and we will create a
new sql database
so with database we had to create a
database server
and then we had to create the database
resource group can be common
for both of the database as well as app
service
so great this looks good let's hit next
here
and we need to configure the connection
string name
how do we want to save the connection
string we will go with the none
option i do not want to configure these
things
we already know the user name is admin
user
and password is admin 123 star
once you do that we have the complete
connection string
right here so make sure you copy this
we will hit the finish button that will
configure the dependencies
and will hit the close once it is done
so you can see sql server has been
configured
next we will edit the deployment mode
here
and we need to change the connection
string
if you expand the database here you see
the connection string
we will remove this and we will paste
the connection string
that we copied we'll select the checkbox
to use this connection string
at runtime on top of that with entity
framework core migrations
if you scroll down we will paste our
connection string
here again and we will say apply
migrations on publish
that way if there are any pending
migrations they will be applied
right now the dotnet 5 is in preview
version
so we will have to change the deployment
mode
from framework dependent to
self-contained
if you do not make that change your
application
will not work once we make all of these
changes
let's hit the publish we have the site
url
right here so once it publishes
it will automatically open up this url
and we will see how things look in azure
great so you can see application has
been deployed
and you see the url that is on azure
if you go on category and in here we can
create a new category let me try to
create one category
with display order and great
you can see it works all the migrations
were applied
automatically and we did not have to do
anything
so with that the free course comes to an
end
but there is much more to learn when it
comes to asp.net core
mvc i have full course which is divided
in two parts
on.netmastery.com in the first part
we will cover more topics on displaying
all the products
and placing enquiry then in the second
part we will focus more on architecture
of our application and we will build the
complete order management in our website
you can find all the details on
dotnetmastery.com
so good luck and i hope to see you guys
in the detailed courses